Hahaha..
Ich sch varies.
You serious?
Ist das dein Ernst?
Hahaha
So, ich bin da
Das wurde mir gerade auf YouTube empfohlen
Das wurde mir gerade eben auf YouTube empfohlen
Ich hab keine Ahnung warum
Hahaha
Das ist richtig dumm
Das ist richtig eng geblieben
Ich weiß auch nicht warum ich ein Video von 2018 empfohlen krieg
Hahaha
Keine Ahnung, ist übelst lustig
Oh
Hä?
Ohje, wo da vorne?
Oh, K.S.
Haaa
Um nicht zu sagen
Oh, Aro B.S.T.
Warte mal Leute
So, sehr schön
Haaa
Pater, oh herrli, drei Monate, dankeschön, richtige Hacker-Mans hier wieder
Massive Subscriber
Nice
So, alle am Start hier, ich seh schon, wer ist denn da?
Der Tribulon ist am Start, Seister ist am Start
Disres1337, oh, exzellent Name heute wieder, ich seh's schon
Die 900 IQ im Titel, die sind gerechtfertigt, wenn ich dir schon wieder seh im Chat alles
BrianL4, Phoenix, Emiloildon, wie auch immer, falls es ausspricht
Der Provokateur, der Kommentator, rilrenaxxdxdxdxdxd
Du hättest die Leute voll verwirren können, wenn du den Namen so lang gemacht hättest und einfach mit Dx angefangen hättest
Und es hätte jeder gesagt, xdxdxd, obwohl es dxdxdx ist, da hättest du alle richtig chibaten können
You got chibated, you got, you got chibated, you got chibated
Wusstet ihr, dass Bill Gates der Schuldige ist? Jetzt ist er enttarnt, Leute
Ich hab's heute auf Twitter gelesen und wenn Twitter das sagt, dann muss das stimmen
Dann kann das nicht sein, da muss das so sein, wenn Twitter das sagt
Bill Gates ist schuld, ich hab mir schon kurzzeitig überlegt
Ob ich nicht auch vielleicht ne Firma gründen sollte, die sich mit medizinischen Produkten beschäftigt, dass mir Bill Gates auch 40 Millionen gibt
Das wär doch mal ne Idee, wenn Bill Gates doch angeblich alles sponsort, was irgendwie medizinische Geschichten hat mit Einfluss auf Viren und Corona und so
Dann mach ich auch ne Firma und sag ich bin Corona Forscher und dann krieg ich von Bill Gates auch Geld
Ich würd sagen, das sollte man mal machen
Ich hab da auch keine Gewissensbisse, also wenn Bill Gates dann sagt, hier Max, mach mal irgendwie ne Studie, dass die Leute alle meinen Impfstoff verwenden sollen, dann mach ich das
Hab ich keine Probleme mit, solange mir 40 Millionen gibt, ist mir das vollkommen egal
Mach einfach eine Corona App, du meinst ne ordentliche Corona App, so eine, ja aber das Problem ist, es gibt schon so viele Corona Apps und die sind schon alle richtig schlecht
Dauert viel zu lange, das stimmt Trivolon, das stimmt
Das ist richtig
Mal gucken, wie lange es Vodafone heute mitmacht, müssen wir mal schauen, mal gucken, wie lange das heute funktioniert
Oh, der Pepega Board ist wieder am Start, ich sehs
Ein paar Fragen vom letzten Mal, aber nicht mal viele
Oh, der Q-Chat in Person ist wieder da, ich sehs schon
Sag mal, irgendwie ist die Lautstärke heute komisch, ich habs auf 18, deswegen stimmt das alles nicht
Jetzt, jetzt ist es auch besser, guck mal hier
So muss das sein, und ich glaube
Dass Teams heute wieder mein Mikrofon verstellt hat, kann das sein?
Natürlich, so eine scheiß Software, alter
So ein Rotz, warum verstellt Teams immer mein Mikrofon?
Warum verstellt Teams immer mein Mikrofon?
Kacke, also
Da reicht, da reicht das schon immer
Diese Organisation, da seid ihr dran schuld
Das ist alles nur um den Chat zu erfreuen
Das ist ja nicht so, dass ich Spaß an meinem Desktop hätte, das ist nur für den Chat
Guck, das sind alles Emotes, die wir haben, alles Emotes-Sachen, was die Leute wissen wollen
Irgendwelche Projekte, alles für den Chat
Aber der Chat ist eh immer dran schuld, insofern ist das also nichts Neues
Oh, jetzt ist es ja ein bisschen laut, oder?
Jetzt ist es ja ein bisschen laut
So
So, ähm
Ich habe übrigens auch eine Idee gehabt für einen der nächsten Streams
Und zwar, mir ist nämlich eingefallen, ich wollte mir schon mal seit Ewigkeiten wieder Timescript angucken
Heute Zoom, Alter Zoom, wirklich
Zoom ist ja auch so ein Ding
Die hätten glaube ich gar nicht damit gedacht, dass die auf einmal durch die Deckel gehen
Also wer in Zoom investiert hat, der ist Big Brain
Ähm
Ich habe übrigens gelesen, es ist demnächst irgendein Xbox Event
Es ist irgendein Xbox Event, die nächsten, über morgen oder so
Xbox Series X Event, was auch immer
Jetzt gucken wir uns vielleicht, vielleicht gucken wir uns das zusammen an
Ja und ich wollte mir mal eine Runde Timescript wieder angucken
Ich habe mir das angeguckt, als es noch Beta war oder noch vor 1.0
Also als das ganz frisch war
Weil äh
Ich mitgekriegt habe, dass der Typ, der damals aus dem C Sharp Team
Das C Sharp Team war
Microsoft geleitet hat, dass der jetzt Timescript macht
Und ich persönlich fand der JavaScript schon immer nervig
Und ich habe mir das vor Ewigkeiten angeguckt
Aber ich glaube, mittlerweile ist es komplett anders
Das sind immer noch Beta, nee die sind doch mittlerweile bei Version 5 oder so
Okay
Version 3.8, nee da ist nix Beta
Es ist heute eben Trend, dass Sachen Beta sind
Hast du dir schon mal eine Runde Timescript angeschrieben?
Ja? Hast du dir schon Crucible angesehen?
Crucible, das klingt wie aus
Ach das Ding
Ganz kurz
Das haben wir uns, das glaube ich sogar im Stream
Ganz kurz habe ich mir das angeguckt
Ich fand das sehr unbeeindruckend
Was man da gesehen hat
Ich weiß noch nicht, was mit den Leuten los ist
Warum macht man jetzt einen Overwatch Konkurrent?
Jetzt nachdem Overwatch quasi dead ist
Ich weiß auch nicht, was dabei ist
Tribolon sagt, Clip einer Vorlesung
Okay, die müssen wir uns jetzt mal kurz angucken
Dafür machen wir auch die Epic Chillstep Collection aus
Also Vorlesung von Tribolon
So und dann klappt das
What?
Okay, Dankeschön für die Teilnahme. Gibt es noch Fragen?
Hier ist die Frage, ob ich Universitätsprofessor bin
Das hier ist die Hochschule Hof, eine Fachhochschule
Na geht doch
Hier Tribolon, es geht doch
Also als erste, was ich da schon mal feststelle
Es ist Java
Das was mich ja persönlich schon ein bisschen abschreckt
Aber okay, es ist auch 69 Leute schon im Stream
Sind dann wieder schnell am Start
Es ist Eclipse und es ist Java
Aber guck mal, Audioqualität gut
Bildqualität ist gut
Gut, es ist ein Mac
Und es ist Java
Aber die Kombination könnte schöner sein
Aber es ist an sich doch okay
Ja, finde ich auch, dass das nice ist
Ich finde das gut
Ja, also das hatte ich mir kurz angeguckt
Hier, von Amazon ist das ja
Dieses Reveal
Alter, halte die Klappe
Allein schon die Aussprache
Also es hat mich überhaupt nicht beeindruckt
Also erstmal, huge Bildqualität, by the way
Und es hat mich überhaupt nicht beeindruckt
Hat mich überhaupt nicht beeindruckt
Eigentlich juckt es überhaupt nicht mehr
Overwatch ist dead
Und jetzt machen sie eine Overwatch Konkurrenz
Mit dem Sinn von
Ja, richtig ppega aim
Das verstehe ich nicht so genau
Und ich glaube ja auch nicht
Dass Overwatch 2 wahnsinnig einschlagen wird
Was kommt denn das eigentlich?
Gibt es da schon was?
2020 irgendwann, ne?
Nein Google, in dem Fall hast du nicht recht
Das steht glaube ich noch nicht fest
Aber irgendwann 2020 haben sie es glaube ich angekündigt
Oder irgendeinen Shop hat es geleakt
Oder ich weiß nicht mehr
Aber es muss eigentlich 2020 kommen
Overwatch ist 4 Jahre alt jetzt
Overwatch ist ganz schön alt schon
Kommt mir gar nicht so lange vor
4 Jahre alt
Und da muss jetzt immer was rankommen
Das Spiel wird nach 2 Jahren tot sein
Du meinst jetzt das Amazon Overwatch
Ja, das glaube ich auch
Und es wird dann auch wieder
Amazon Overwatch, ja das glaube ich auch
Wenn du mal was programmieren
könntest du mal mit Git arbeiten
Dass ich einen Überblick über den Workflow bekomme
Ja
Können wir heute machen, tatsächlich
Poggers, können wir heute machen
Ich darf meine Secrets Datei
nicht aufmachen, Leute
Sonst leake ich mein WLAN Passwort
Und sonst Leak ich mein WLAN Passport Leute
Oh ich hab, egal, ich hab meine IP doch eh schon geleakt
IP Leak vorbei, RIP jetzt ist, jetzt ist raus
Ja wie siehts bei euch so aus, TypeScript mäßig, wollen wir uns das mal angucken
Wie gesagt ich hab es mir schon vor Jahren mal angeschaut aber ich würde gerne mal so
eine kleine Beispiel oder so eine kleine Anwendung mal TypeScript basteln
Gucken wie das so ist, ich de-dosse die IP, ja mach mal, mal gucken was mein Router aushält
Kap
Was kann das, also ich kann dir nur sagen wofür TypeScript gut war vor 4 Jahren oder
5 Jahren oder wann auch immer, wie ewig das her ist, nee noch länger, ich hab es wirklich
ganz schnell, wo ich das ausprobiert hab, das war eine Javascript kompatibler Aufsatz
im Endeffekt um Javascript mit Type, also mit Typinformationen anzureichern, also sprich
du konntest dann sagen, in Javascript oder in TypeScript in dem Fall, aber man muss sagen
das TypeScript ist Javascript, also alles gültiges Javascript ist auch gültiges TypeScript
oder umgedreht nicht und du konntest dann sagen zum Beispiel, diese Variable ist Typ
String, diese Variable ist Typ Int, also so wie man das aus C Sharp, C++, Rust, normalen
ordentlichen Programmiersprachen kennt und das konnte man damit auch machen und das Coole
daran war, dass man halt einige Fehler, die man in Javascript sonst nur zur Runtime merkt,
schon direkt beim Programmieren feststellen kann.
Die Sündags fand ich auch ganz schön, die waren damals ihrer Zeit ein bisschen voraus,
wie gesagt 2012 oder 2013, wann ich mir das angeguckt hab, da gab es den neuen Javascript
Standard oder einen der neuen, da blickt da keiner mehr durch, was da gerade aktuell ist,
Javascript Standards noch nicht und da haben sie manche Sachen schon eingebaut, die dann
quasi erst kommen sollten mit dem nächsten Standard, ich weiß nicht wie es jetzt aussieht,
ne Javascript kann das nicht, Javascript kann ein bisschen was in die Richtung, aber das
ist voll der Krampf, man kann in Javascript, wenn man eine Funktion programmiert, kann
man dort einen Hilfetext davor schreiben und wenn man einen ordentlichen Editor hat, der
zeigt dann an, also der passt den Hilfetext von einer Funktion und kann dann daraus ableihen,
ah das sollte ein String sein, ah das sollte ein Int sein oder so, aber das ist nichts,
was dann quasi wirklich sagt, nein das ist falsch, das geht an der Stelle nicht.
Python 3 hat mittlerweile Type Pins, echt, wirklich, das ist ja cool, da haben die sich
doch immer so dagegen gewehrt, da hat man immer gesagt so ein scheiß Pauma nicht, ah
es ist ja lustigerweise fast die gleiche, fast die gleiche Syntax wie Typescript, nur nur
das hier, das macht man mit Typescript glaube ich nicht, aber das hier ist fast die gleiche
Syntax und das ist in 3.5, 3.5 ist noch auch schon eine ganze Weile raus, 3,5 Inches, weiß
nicht was Google mir mitteilen möchte, wann kam das raus, wenn man nicht schreiben kann,
ja das ist auch schon 5 Jahre alt, seit 5 Jahren haben die das schon, habe ich überhaupt
nicht mitgekriegt, ja das kennen wir ja schon, das kennen wir schon, das haben wir uns oft
genug angeguckt, dass Sachen die in Javascript nicht so funktionieren wie man es erwartet,
da gibt es ja jede Menge Sachen, Javascript ist halt ziemlich, wo haben wir passende E-Mode
für, ziemlich brain dead, so also was wir heute machen, ich zeige euch mal was, ich
habe ein paar Fotos gemacht, so kann man mal ein Steam-Stats aufmachen, Steamlabs, Dashboard,
ja, geh auf, will nicht, geht nicht auf, ach hier, jetzt ist offen, also wen haben wir
noch am Start, gerade eben, selfmade ice, prime subscription, dankeschön, huge brain, subscription
hier, nice, ein nicer sub, die Bella Twitch TV gehen wohl nicht richtig im Chat, immer
noch nicht, das hatten wir das letzte Mal noch schon, das muss ich mir mal aufschreiben,
dass ich das mal danach fixen kann, warum gehen die nicht, was ist da los, aber Bella
Twitch, aber FFZ-E-Modes gehen oder, KegW habe ich über FFZ drinne, das muss funktionieren,
der Wendler geht nicht komisch, sehr merkwürdig, guckt FFZ-E-Modes gehen, das weiß ich nicht,
das muss ich mir nach dem Stream mal angucken, weil da muss ich wahrscheinlich den Browser-Link
austauschen und den Browser-Link will ich euch jetzt nicht zeigen im Stream, gut, also
demnächst gucken wir uns mal eine Runde Typescript an, ich zeige euch mal was ich gebastelt habe,
das Bild von meiner Türgegensprechanlage kennt ihr ja schon, hatten wir ja schon mal
hier, da, also das Telefon von der Türgegensprechanlage und ich hab euch jetzt noch ein paar weitere
Fotos gemacht, nämlich von dem Controller und der Konstruktion, die ich da dran gehängt
hab, weil hier war ja schon alles eingebaut, ich hab bloß ein bisschen was verkackt, das
eine hab ich nicht richtig isoliert, weiß ich nicht ob es da dran liegt, dass das manchmal
rumspackt und ich glaube irgendwie hab ich was abgerissen oder so, als ich das da hinter
die Dose gequetscht hab, deswegen zeige euch jetzt mal was ich jetzt gebaut hab und bevor
ich das jetzt einbaue, hab ich gedacht wir machen das jetzt mal ordentlich im Stream
fertig, so da muss ich jetzt euch bloß mal das Bild zeigen, so, oh huge, wahnsinnsgröße,
also Leute ich hoffe ihr erkennt alles, ist klar oder, also das hier ist die Gegensprechanlage
offen und das hier ist das was ich heute zusammen gelötet hab und wie man hier ganz klar erkennt
ist das hier der Sensor, da klar kann ich da draufklicken, ich hab gedacht ich muss
furchtbar lustig sein, aber es hat nicht funktioniert, der Chat hat mich durchschaut, noch ein bisschen
kleiner ist kein Problem, so, ich glaub so ist das exzellent, war schon mega funny,
oh guck mal das geht auch so, ja also so ich zeig es euch jetzt nochmal richtig, warum
blendet Chrome eigentlich nicht ein, ne oder das ist gar kein Chrome, das ist FireFox,
hat FireFox früher nicht oben eingeblendet welche Vergrößerungssachen die Seite hat?
haben die da keine Lust mehr drauf, haben die gedacht ne das braucht man nicht, immer
noch wo ist es, das ist das Chrome, das ist kein Chrome, das ist FireFox, ich sehs nicht,
seht ihr es irgendwo, ich sehs nicht, wo ist es, hier seh ichs ja das ist klar aber normalerweise
haben die das auch immer hier oben eingeblendet und vielleicht ist mein ach was auch immer
FireFox sonst was man muss die Sache nicht hinterfragen, ähm ergibt nicht unbedingt
alles immer Sinn was da passiert, ja genau, äh Kampf Kevin genau da hab ich das normalerweise
auch, aber irgendwie hat der FireFox keinen Bock drauf, wie dem auch sei es soll uns jetzt
nicht weiter stören, heute schon Pacman gemacht wieso gab es ne neue ähm, neue, gabs irgendwelche
Sicherheitslücken oder so, zugucken hab ich was verpasst, achso du meinst wegen dem FireFox
ne hab ich nicht, aber wahrscheinlich äh wird der jetzt auch ne halbe Stunde aktualisieren
und da hab ich kein Bock drauf, weißt du das lassen wir, das lassen wir sein, ähm so also
ich zeige euch jetzt mal das ganze was ich zusammengebaut hab, also einmal haben wir
hier meine Klingel, also quasi das da in offen, also sprich das da bloß mal aufgemacht, äh
und hier ist das was ich zusammen gelötet hab, so, ähm hier oben hängt normalerweise
ein 12 Volt auf 5 Volt USB, ähm Spannungswanzler drin, den hab ich da gerade abgemacht, so
hier an diesen Pappern hängt das, den wollte ich da nicht mit Heißkleber rein machen,
weil dann krieg ich ihn dann mal richtig ab, ohne das Ding kaputt zu machen, ach Sebaro ist
das heute, du bist wieder, du bist wieder bestens informiert wie ich sehe, so also hier sieht
man das, der hintere davon, das ist die Gegensprechanlage, also das Telefon von der Gegensprechanlage
und hier hinten hab ich den Controller reingestopft, jetzt geht, what, excellent Firefox, alles
klar, richtige Hacker man, genau Zuschauer, das wirds gewesen sein, vor allem das abbrechen,
das wirds gewesen sein, so, so sieht das offen aus, also sprich zur Erklärung was man da
sieht von der Klingel, also hier, das sind die zwei Kabel, die außen an die Gegenstelle
gehen an der Straße, also sprich Siedle macht das so, das sind nur zwei Kabel, einmal Ground
und einmal Signalgeschiss, ich hab das letzte Mal schon ungefähr erklärt, wie das Ganze
funktioniert, die haben eine sehr merkwürdige Technik dahinter, das ist super obskur und
jetzt, bisschen grotesk wie das funktioniert, das Ganze nennt sich Siedle 1 plus N, so und
da gibt es dann ein Handbuch dazu, wir gucken da jetzt nicht lange rein, ich will euch bloß
mal zeigen wie verrückt die Technik von denen ist, und zwar wie das funktioniert ist, jetzt
muss ich mal nach 24 Volts suchen, falls man das findet, genau, hier steht Funktionsweise,
die erklären dir das, wie das über die zwei Kabel funktioniert, das ist wirklich Big Brain,
also wenn nichts ist, also sprich wenn keiner spricht mit dem Telefon, wenn keiner klingelt,
dann ist hier drauf, dann sind hier drauf 18 Volt, DC wohlgemerkt, 18 Volt, so, wenn
einer klingelt, dann steigt das kurzzeitig hier auf 24 Volt und kurz nachdem einer geklingelt
hat, geht die Spannung auf 15 Volt, auf dem da, auf 7, also exzellente Taktik, so anhand
dieser unterschiedlichen Spannung erkennt halt dann dieses Telefon, ob es klingeln
muss, ob es telefonieren muss oder was auch immer es machen muss, so und die schreiben
ja glücklicherweise halbwegs hier wie das ganze funktioniert, wie das aufgebaut ist,
so und das ich jetzt mitbekomme, ob jemand geklingelt hat, das habe ich ja im letzten
Stream schon erzählt, wie das auch ein bisschen genauer, aber ich werde es jetzt noch mal
grob erzählen, dass man der ganzen Sache halbwegs folgen kann, also was ich gemacht
habe ist, jetzt aber halt mal ordentlich, so dass es auch ein bisschen kleiner ist und
zusammenpasst, ich habe ein bisschen was zusammengelötet heute und zwar haben wir einmal hier,
ich habe, ich muss den, ich zeige euch gleich was unter dem Schrumpfschlauch ist noch, so
also einmal haben wir hier den ESP32, so ein Microcontroller, den hier, der da, der ist
ganz vor zu klein, der kostet auch ein bisschen mehr als ein normaler AliExpress ESP32, der
ist ganz klein und das ist wichtig, dass der ganz klein ist, denn der muss da rein, da
ist so eine normale, wie nennt man das, Dose, Unterputzdose, wie nennt man so ein Loch,
so ein rundes Loch in der Wand ist da, was da mal irgend einer reingefräst hat, geschnitten
hat, wie auch immer man das da macht, genau, so und der kommt dann da hinten rein, das
heißt ich kann da gar kein so ein fettes ESP32-Board nehmen, weil das passt da nicht rein, das
passt da rein, deswegen ist das schonmal so ein kleines Board, so und was da dran ist,
ist die Pin-Belege und so, ist jetzt nicht, ist jetzt erstmal egal, müssen wir mal klein
mal nachgucken, so genau, was man hier sieht, ist einmal der Sensor, das ist ein Magnetsensor,
also da spricht, der erkennt, ob ein magnetisches Feld in der Nähe ist und was ich damit mache
ist, ich erkenne, ob der Hörer aufgelegt ist oder nicht, der Hörer selbst hat kein
Schalter, der Hörer selbst hat ein Magnet drin und ich steck einfach in diesem Gehäuse
dann, der 5-Hat, aber Massive, excellent, 5-Hat ist das, das ist 6, also Leute, eigentlich
schon so oder, ja sehbar, seh ich auch so, eigentlich ist das schon 6-Hat, so und das
hat kein Schalter, das hängt ja einfach nur drauf und ich steck das immer, ich hab jetzt
leider die Vorderseite nicht nochmal fotografiert, man kann es dann hier dahinter stecken, hinter
das Telefon, das hat sogar extra so eine Vertiefung an der Stelle, das passt, das heißt hiermit
kann ich erkennen, ob das Telefon aufgehängt ist oder nicht, das ist ein, wen das interessiert,
wer sich fragt, was das für ein Magnetsensor ist, kann ich euch zeigen, das ist ein, ich
glaub das ist, wo hab ich das, ich glaub bei Konrad, Hall-Sensor, aha, aha, ahi, Bane's
Jam, 3661, ich glaub der ist das, ah, excellent Produktname also, kann man sich natürlich
wunderbar merken, Hall-Sensor, aha, 3661 UA 2,4, alles klar und ihr seht, der Kram kostet
nicht viel, der ist sogar noch ein bisschen teuer geworden, die kriegste wahrscheinlich
für unter den Euro das Stück, also generell, es lohnt sich wirklich, wenn ein bisschen
was bastelt, es lohnt sich, oh, H-Leak, H-Reveal, OMFG, es lohnt sich wirklich, anstatt sich
diese fertigen Boards zu kaufen, die es oftmals gibt, wo im Endeffekt einfach nur einer hingegangen
ist, diesen Sensor genommen hat und auf ein Board gesteckt hat und ein paar Output Pins
dran gemacht hat, diesen Sensor selbst zu kaufen, so ein fertiges Board, wo quasi schon Pins
dran gelötet sind und alles, bezahlste in Deutschland auch wahrscheinlich 5, 6 Euro,
viel zu teuer und kaufst du den Sensor allein, kriegste den für sogar unter einem Euro das
Stück, das ist ja sogar noch relativ teuer und ihr wisst ja, ich kaufe mir immer 10
Stück, das sind 99 Euro 10 Stück, kaufst du euch 10 Stück, 9 Euro irgendwas, 9,90 Euro
gut ist, braucht man zwar nicht so viel, aber wie gesagt, Reserve ist nie verkehrt.
Ja, Sebaro habe ich auch gerade festgestellt, ich weiß nicht, woran es liegt, das muss
ich nach dem Stream irgendwie mal fixen, ich weiß nicht, woran das liegt, das können wir
nicht auf Vodafone schieben, vielleicht können wir es auf die Bahn schieben, die hat schon
lange nichts mehr angestellt, ich glaube aber in dem Fall liegt es an Steamlabs, die irgendwas
an ihrer Chatfunktion geändert haben und ich muss wahrscheinlich neue Steamlabs generieren
oder sowas, so, genau, das hatte ich gerade, also wie gesagt, das ist das Ding womit man
erkennt, ob das Telefon aufgesetzt ist oder nicht, also abgehoben ist oder nicht, das
werden wir uns jetzt auch gleich angucken hier, also dann hier live, so, dann haben wir hier,
da sieht man jetzt leider nicht so viel, ich zeige euch aber mal ein Foto davon, was da
unten drunter ist, aber wohlgemerkt, das ist Foto, was ich euch jetzt zeige, ist nicht
von mir, aber da ist genau das gleiche drunter, IO Broker, ich glaube wir hatten das schon
mal auf, oder auch nicht, ach was suchen wir dann, ja, so, der Typ, nach der Anleitung von
dem Typ habe ich das gemacht, allerdings nicht die erste Anleitung von ihm, sondern die,
die ein bisschen weiter unten drunter gepostet ist, da, da sieht man es, was da eigentlich
drunter ist, und bei mir sieht das genauso aus, es hat also gar keinen Sinn, dass ich
das jetzt irgendwie fotografierte, also sprich, das was hier drunter ist, unter diesem Schrumpfschlauch,
der nicht geschrumpft ist, der einfach nur drüber gezogen ist, ist genau das hier drunter,
und zwar einmal, sieht man das hier, ein Optokoppler PC817, ich wusste bis zu dem Zeitpunkt nicht,
weil das es sowas gibt, ehrlich gesagt, bevor ich das gesehen habe, das ist quasi so eine
Art Relay, bloß dass es optisch geschaltet wird, dann haben wir hier einmal die Verbindung
zu, zum Crown Pin auf eins, und das hier ist ein 470 Ohm Widerstand und eine, hoi, kriege
ich das jetzt noch zusammen, eine 20 Volt Z-Diode, wusste ich auch nicht, dass es sowas
gibt, ich bin ein absoluter Elektronik Noob, ich kann die zwei Sachen zwar ganz gut zusammenlöten,
Ahnung habe ich nicht wirklich davon, zumindest sorgt das Ganze dafür, dass wenn einer klingelt,
wenn hier einer klingelt, dann haben wir ja gerade gesehen in dem Handbuch von Siedle,
dass dann hier 24 Volt drauf sind, so, und was diese Z-Diode hier macht ist, die blockiert
quasi alles und ab 20 Volt geht das quasi durch, so und das heißt dann im Endeffekt,
sobald über 20 Volt anliegen, also 24 beim Klingeln, fließt hier Strom durch, so, und
dadurch, dass hier Strom durch fließt, schaltet der Optokoppler diese Seite auch an, also
das ist quasi, wenn man so eine Art Relay plus Optisch, der Vorteil davon ist, dass
das optisch ist, man hat keinerlei Verbindung zwischen diesem Stromkreis hier und zwischen
diesem und hier ist das, wo der Controller dran kommt, ist 24 Volt nicht etwas viel,
ich meine Steckdose hat 230 Volt, hä, den Sebaro, das verstehe ich nicht, das ist mir
jetzt zu hoch gerade, was du meinst, so und hier kommt dann der Controller dran, das sieht
man hier, das hier, das ist auf die Seite, die geht hier auf Pin, ich glaube 21 und hier
auf Ground, das ist bei mir dran, so und so funktioniert das und weil wegen zu viel Strom,
was, müsste das nicht komplett klühen, das ist ja auch nicht an der Steckdose dran Sebaro,
das sind maximal 24 Volt die hier durchgehen, nee 24 ist nicht viel, da kannst du dran greifen
ohne dass dir irgendwas passiert, das ist nicht wild, also ich glaube auf ein Klingeldraht
von der Telekom sind glaube ich, das war irgendwas ganz scheppes oder 63 Volt oder sowas, Telefondose,
60 Volt, ja und wenn du da dran greifst, dann zwickt es ein bisschen, das weiß ich aus
eigener Erfahrung, ja und was da maximal durch stimmt, Chat ist wieder Massive Brain, das
ist richtig, maximal 1,3 Ampere können es sein hier, also da kann dir nichts passieren,
mehr macht das Netzteil nicht, wo das angeschlossen ist, aber trotzdem würde ich da nicht unbedingt
dran fassen und dran rumfuddeln, als quasi mit der nackten Hand dran greifen, weil ich
weiß nicht wie rauf das Ding reagiert, wenn du da irgendwie Kurzschluss fabrizierst, was
ab 50 mA ist es doch tödlich, also ich weiß ja nicht, da müsstest du ja bei jedem Mikrocontroller
wo du dran greifst sterben, mA das juckt doch kein Mensch, wenn ich mir angucke ElectroBoom
greift teilweise ansonstige, was auch immer für Dinge da dran und kriegt einen Schlag,
also ich hab davon auch nicht wirklich großartig planen, zumindest in solchen Regionen hab
ich da auch schon dran gegriffen und da passiert dir nichts, aber ich würde es nicht machen,
weil ich keine Ahnung hab, wie das ganze Tür-Gegensprechanlagen-Ding darauf reagiert, wenn du da Kurzschluss fabrizierst.
Leute ich glaub was ihr meint ist nicht mA, sondern das m in dem Fall für ne Ecke größer,
also was kommt da als nächstes mega oder so, Meter, ja es kommt wahrscheinlich auch
ein bisschen drauf an, also ich mein was kommt denn dabei rum, 24V mit 1A, das müssten dann
noch genau 24W sein oder, mal 1, 1A, 24V, der Chat ist auch gerade viel zu big brain
für mich, also ich kann mir nicht vorstellen, dass das großartig was macht, ich mein ich
würd nicht dran greifen, nicht unbedingt jetzt aus Sorge, dass mir was passieren würde,
sondern eher, dass ich das Ding irgendwie kurzschließe und es kaputt geht, das muss
nicht sein, ich pass da immer auf, so also wo sind wir stehen geblieben, genau also das
hab ich heute noch vor dem Stream zusammengelötet, 50mA kann am Herz negativ einfach sein, kann
alles sein, kein Schimmer, aber in den Spannungsbereichen mach ich mir ehrlich gesagt, hab ich mir noch
nie großartig Gedanken drüber gemacht, also alles bis PoE hab ich keine Bedenken, alles
da drüber mach ich nicht und PoE sind 48V maximal glaube, ja Ante das kann ich mir vorstellen,
so genau so und das Ding hab ich jetzt hier neben mir liegen und da werden wir jetzt ein
bisschen dran rum basteln und gucken wie das funktioniert und nachdem es natürlich doof
ist, wenn man das einfach nur hier programmiert und es nicht funktioniert und man nicht ausprobieren
kann, ob es geht, hab ich mir was überlegt, weil der Chat und diesmal war es tatsächlich
der Chat, der hat mir ja letztens was auf Amazon, als wir hier am einkaufen waren, ich glaub
ich hab sogar noch hier im wahren Korb, zeige mal her ja
und zwar der Chat, irgendjemand von dem ich zumindest den Eindruck hatte, er weiß wovon
er redet, hat mir letztens auf Amazon dieses Ding hier rausgesucht und zwar kann man damit,
aber dafür verwende ich es gerade nicht muss ich sagen, irgendeinen Spannungswandel herausgesucht
für von AC nach DC und was ich jetzt gemacht hab ist, ich hab nen, was hab ich da dran?
mal draufgucken, weiß gar nicht, was hab ich denn da für nen, was hab ich denn, ich muss
doch kurz gucken, was ich für ein Netzteil dran hab, warte mal, nicht dass ich das Teil
sich kaputtmache, ahja, also ich hatte noch, ich hatte noch von ner uralt, von ner uralt,
ich glaub uralt Speedport oder so war das, irgendwas ganz altes, hatte ich noch 22 Volt
AC Netzteil, das hab ich da dran angeschlossen und hab's jetzt eingestellt auf 24 Volt DC
oder?
irgendwie so war's, zumindest auf 21 Volt DC hab ich glaub ich eingestellt, ich hab's
maximale genommen was ging und das funktioniert auch, ich hab keine Ahnung ob das dem Ding
gut tut, aber damit kann man das hier simulieren, was die Klingel macht beim Klingeln, weil
die Klingel wie gesagt hat hier 24 Volt DC drauf, wenn's klingelt und das kann ich damit
jetzt nachstellen, einer der Gründe warum ich mir schon seit langer Zeit mal nen Labornetzteil
kaufen will, damit ich sowas mal machen kann, aber hab ich bis jetzt noch nicht gekauft,
das heißt ich hab jetzt hier dieses Ding angeschlossen, ah ne mal Amazon, ich hab jetzt hier dieses
Ding angeschlossen und ich kann jetzt quasi auf Knopfdruck so tun als würde es klingeln,
bau dir doch nen Labornetzteil selber, also mit meinen wahnsinnig krassen Elektrotechnik
Kenntnissen ist das sicherlich eine sehr gute Idee, wenn ich mir einen Labornetzteil selber
bau, nachdem wir ja gerade so viele Big Brain Elektro Leute im Chat haben, was ist denn ein
gutes Labornetzteil, also ein gutes Bench Power Supply, wie sie das auf Englisch nennen,
was taugt denn da, kann man da auch China nehmen, weil China ist in der Regel bei sowas
immer ziemlich günstig und hat gute Features, ich weiß aber nicht ob man das wirklich machen
sollte, von Aliexpress, warum nicht, habt ihr da irgendwie ne gute Empfehlung für Labornetzteile,
was man da kaufen kann, bespell dir noch eins bei Wish, da kommt bestimmt was richtig
cooles bei raus, Wish-Netzteil, so, by the way, ach ne man siehts jetzt gar nicht, ha
doof, man sieht noch ein bisschen Heißkleber, ich hab das wieder fachmännisch, fachmännisch
korrekt gemacht, ehrlich gesagt ich weiß nicht ob man das so macht, und zwar hier,
dass es hier keinen Kurzschluss gibt, weil ich mein es könnte ja sein, dass beim Einbauen,
dass ich das hier verschiebe und dass die Kontakte zusammenkommen, das ist nicht gut,
deswegen hab ich mir gedacht, ich mach einfach den Big Brain Move und mach einfach auf jede
Seite einen großen Klecks Heißkleber drauf, dann kann nix mehr zusammen gehen, so also
im Prinzip hab ich das Ding genommen, wie gesagt das ist nicht mein Foto, aber sieht
genauso aus, das Ding hab ich zugeheißklebert und hab's in den Schrumpfschlauch gesteckt,
fertig, aus ist, genau, und den Schrumpfschlauch hab ich mal in weiser Voraussicht, weil ich
kenn mich, ich muss den Scheiß bestimmt mal wieder aufmachen, solange ich es noch nicht
eingebaut habe oder nur nicht abschließend einbaue, noch nicht geschrumpft, weil ich
hab das schon ein paar mal gemacht, dass ich gedacht, oh ja machst du einen Schrumpfschlauch
drüber, puste, puste, puste, ah ja wunderbar, sitzt gut, das ist auch scheiße, du musst
nochmal abmachen, da muss ich den ganzen Scheiß wieder aufschneiden, deswegen hab ich jetzt
erstmal nur drüber gezogen, kann man machen ist aber nicht so geil, was macht man denn
sonst, also mal angenommen ich hab hier sowas konstruiert, und ich will halt ausschließen,
dass hier irgendwie das da mit dem zusammenkommt, Schrumpfschlauch mit Kabelbinder festmachen,
das ist eine gute Idee, in dem Fall brauch ich es nicht, das steckt da ziemlich fest
drinne, wegen den großen Klecksen Heißkleber, das ist halt recht dick und passt da kaum
rein, aber das mit Kabelbinder finde ich ist eine gute Idee, wo wir da by the way gerade
bei sind, ich brauch mal wieder ein ordentliches kleine Kabelbinderpack, hier sowas da, wie
viel sind das, 100 Stück, exzellent, aber die sind doch bestimmt Müll, oder 100 Stück,
das ist bestimmt China Crap, hat hier mal eine Empfehlung für Kopfhörer, für was,
fürs Spielen, fürs Musikhören, für wie willst du es haben, Bass lastig, besonders
neutral, da steht Premium Qualität, dann wirds stimmen, wie wir ja alle wissen, wenn
das der China Hersteller auf Amazon schreibt, dann stimmt das immer, ok, ja gut, so jetzt
fangen wir mal an, was ich jetzt hab, ist wie gesagt, ich hab hier dran die Fake Klingel
angeschlossen, also wie gesagt, die Fake Klingel angeschlossen, die ich euch gerade
gezeigt hab, sprich hier, das 24 Volt Netzteil quasi, ist hier angeschlossen, die Fake Klingel,
das heißt dort müsste ich am Input, was ist das, 21, ist das Input 21, ich glaub das
ist Input 21, erkennt man jetzt nicht so richtig gut, ehrlich gesagt, ne, erkennt man doch
ziemlich gut, guck mal hier, richtig gute Kamera, hätte ich gar nicht gedacht, dass
das ein von 23, Input 23 ist das, also an Input 23 erkennen wir gleich die Klingel und
an Input, wo gehts hin, da oben irgendwo, ist natürlich super clever, wie ich das Foto
gemacht hab, an Input 33 erkennen wir gleich, ob der Kopfhörer, oder nicht der Kopfhörer,
warum sag ich Kopfhörer, der Hörer abgenommen ist oder nicht, das testen wir mit nem kleinen
Magnet, ja so siehts aus, das Netzteil hat RGB, das Netzteil hat zwar kein RGB, aber
ich könnte das moden mit RGB, ich hab nämlich noch mal eine Weihnachtsbaumsteuerung, die
liegt hier noch rum, die könnte ich da einfach drüber hängen, mit der LED Lichterkette,
es hat dann zwar keinen wirklichen Sinn, aber es hat RGB, und wir wissen jetzt, dass es
mit RGB prinzipiell kühler bleibt, schneller ist und besser funktioniert, am besten Musik
und bisschen Gaming, also ich persönlich mag ja die hier, also ich hab 5 übertrieben,
ich weiß jetzt kommen sie wieder an, easy money, youtube money, lull, also ich hab 5
Kopfhörer, ich hab einmal, ich zeig dir mal 3 Stück, die ich bedenkenlos empfehlen kann,
nämlich als Headset einmal das hier, aber das ist ja außer Konkurrenz, weil das, nö,
du willst ja kein Headset, das find ich immer noch nach wie vor das beste Headset, unter
der Haube ist das dann DT 770, den kann ich empfehlen, ich hab noch einen DT 990, weil
der offen ist, den hab ich aber so gut wie nie an, aber das ist eher so ein bisschen
auch der DT 770, das ist eher was für die Leute, die gerne so ein bisschen Badewanne
Bass mäßig haben, dann hab ich schon AKG 7, ist das vielleicht sogar der, das könnte
der, ich glaub ich hab noch nen 701, das ist nicht das gleiche, vielleicht ist das der
nachvoll, ne das ist nicht, ich hab noch den mit diesen eklichen Noppen drauf, ich hab
noch die mit diesen eklichen Noppen drauf, die Sacken, ohne Polsternoppen, ja, also ich
geh mal davon aus, dass das einfach ein neueres Modell ist davon, den find ich vom Klang her
richtig gut, der ist, also ich finde rein von dem, wie sich die Sachen anhören, ist
das mein Lieblingskopfhörer, natürlich du kannst, Kopfhörer kannst du bis 20.000 Euro
ausgeben, ja, wir reden jetzt mal von Dingern, die preisleistungsmäßig auch ganz okay sind
und mit denen ich halt schon Erfahrungen gemacht hab, den find ich recht neutral, also sprich
du hörst alle Sachen ungefähr ausgewogen, hört sich auch recht breit an finde ich,
den find ich, also der gefällt mir am besten vom Klang her und die neuen scheinen auch
wohl recht gut bequem auf dem Kopf zu sitzen, ich hab noch nen, wie gesagt ich hab noch
den alten und den alten, hier sieht man es schön, der alte, der hatte hier unter dem
Leder so komische Noppen drauf und ich kann euch sagen, die erste halbe Stunde nervt
euch nicht, aber irgendwann tut euch richtig der Kopf weh wegen diesen komischen Noppen,
da gab es sogar schon erste Leute, die irgendwelche Mods gepostet haben in Foren und sowas, total
bescheuert, dass man sowas überhaupt braucht, aber es scheint so, als wäre das mittlerweile
besser und tut einem mittlerweile nicht mehr auf den Kopf weh, würde der mir nicht auf
den Kopf weh tun, hätt ich den den ganzen Tag auf, so und Tragekomfortmäßig finde
ich, AHA, oh fuck, 700, nee, nein, ATH, oh fuck, wie heißen die Dinger, nee nee nee nee,
Moment, ich muss mal kurz drauf gucken, AD700X, dir gibt es aber auch schon was Neues, Tragekomfortmäßig
ist der hier richtig nice, das ist der bequemste Kopfhörer den es gibt, also den ich kenne,
ja, weil die haben so, den muss man aber mal ausprobieren, ob das Kopfformmäßig passt,
die haben versucht, dass so wenig Druck wie möglich auf den Kopf ausgeübt wird, der
hat relativ große Ohrmuscheln, also da passen die Ohren komplett rein, es ist auch nicht
so dicht wie ein DT770, Tragekomfortmäßig finde ich den mit Abstand am besten, so, jetzt,
volles Programm, also das finde ich, also wenn du einen suchst zum Spielen, zum Hören,
der wirklich sehr bequem ist, wenn er zu deinem Kopf passt, dann kann ich dir den empfehlen,
du musst aber mal gucken, wie gesagt, ich habe die Dinger schon eine ganze Weile, du
musst mal gucken, ob es den Kram nicht schon in neueren Varianten gibt, weil es kann durchaus
sein, dass der Kram so teuer ist gerade, weil er Auslaufmodell ist und kaum noch gibt,
DT770 Pro von Bein, der DT770 ist ja, ich weiß nicht, ob der DT770 sich großartig vom
MMX300 Kopfhörer unterscheidet, wenn ich mir das so angucke, eher, eher nicht, sieht
eigentlich, sieht eigentlich ganz genau so aus, das MMX300 ist bequem, also den kann
man den ganzen Tag aufhaben, das einzige was mich beim MMX300 beziehungsweise beim DT770
stört ist, dass der sich auf der einen Seite ein bisschen Badewanne mäßig anhört und
auf der anderen Seite, dass der halt geschlossen ist und man permanent dadurch halt, dass man,
dass man drum herum nichts hört, dass man permanent so ein bisschen Druckgefühl auf
den Ohren hat, weil der eben so dicht macht, deswegen würde ich das nicht als Kopfhörer
für den ganzen Tag vorm Rechner sitzen und Musik hören nebenbei verwenden, also wie
gesagt, ich finde Tragekomfort ist das Ding der beste, den ich je hatte, lustigerweise
verwende ich ihn selbst, aber ja, gut, weiter gehts, jetzt habe ich euch jetzt alles gezeigt,
was wir hier gebastelt haben, was wir am Start haben und da können wir mal anfangen, so,
wo haben wir das Teil, ahja, um das hier zu testen habe ich so einen kleinen Magnet, da
sieht man das auch gleich, das heißt, was wir jetzt machen ist, wir gehen mal in unsere
Arduino-Gedöns und nein, ich gehe nicht in meine Secrets-PP, weil ich will nicht mein
WLAN-Passwort leaken und ich stöpsel das Ding jetzt mal dran und dann probieren wir
mal aus, auszulesen, ob es klingelt und ob einer den Kopf, Alter, was habe ich mit Kopfhörer,
den Gehörer vom Telefon aufgelegt hat, Face-Gesicht ist auch mal wieder am Start, fünf Monate
richtig krasse Hexos wieder hier, ich sehs schon, der Name ist schon so Lied, da ist
der IQ wieder um 500 gestiegen heute, so, ich stöpsel mal kurz an, hat das an die
VM weitergeleitet, so, jetzt machen wir hier mal die serielle Ausgabe auf, dass wir was
sehen und wir sehen, dass wir nichts sehen, das ist schlecht, ah, jetzt, wir sehen, dass
er I'm Alive ist, so, ich werd mal kurz erzählen zu diesem Sketch, den ich hier schon drinne
hab, das ist zum größten Teil das, was wir in den letzten beiden C++ Streams gebaut
haben, aber ich zeig's nochmal kurz, ich hab nämlich ein paar Sachen ergänzt an der
ganzen Geschichte, also, los geht's, wir ignorieren mal das ganze Zeug, ich zeig's euch mal kurz,
es ist auch echt nicht kompliziert, also das sind die zwei Sachen, die jeder Arduino-Sketch
braucht, das ist die Fault, das geht nicht, der Unterschied ist folgender, Setup wird
einmal ausgeführt und Loop wird quasi permanent durchgeschleift, durchgeloopt, also hier passiert
die eigentliche Logik drinne, normalerweise, und hier passiert, Alter, Setup, was man einmalig
nach dem Starten, nach dem Starten ausführt, so, und was wir das letzte Mal programmiert
haben ist, dass man den ESP32 übers WLAN updaten kann, und zwar über HTTPS, und das war gar
nicht so einfach, ich hab das jetzt mal versucht hier, ein bisschen schöner zu machen, das,
was wir im letzten Stream gemacht haben, das hab ich alles hier in diese Admin-Datei gepackt,
das ist, das müssen wir uns jetzt, wir können uns das später mal angucken, wenn ihr wollt,
so, das ist mehr oder weniger das, was wir im letzten Stream zusammen programmiert haben,
so, was der macht ist, nach einem Neustart, macht er erstmal hier die serielle Verbindung
auf, dass ich überhaupt Ausgabetext sehen kann, dann ruft er die Startup-Funktion auf,
so, und das ist eigentlich da, wo alles passiert, in Startup gibt er einmal aus, dass er bootet,
er initialisiert das WLAN, gucken wir uns an, was er da macht, der nimmt die config von
hier oben, setzt eine IP, setzt ein Gateway, setzt eine Network-Mask und setzt ein DNS,
ersetzt eine Hostname, in dem Fall ESP32-Klingelsensor, dann disconnectet der WLAN, falls es irgendwie
noch hängt oder rumspackt oder was auch immer, dann setzen wir das WLAN in den Station-Mode,
also sprich als WLAN client und nicht als Access-Point, dann sagen wir, dass wir nicht
auto-connecten wollen, sonst würde er nämlich die WLAN-Daten im Flash speichern und ich
will meinen WLAN-Passport nicht im Flash gespeichert haben, falls ich meinen Controller mal in
Müll schmeiße und wir sagen Auto-reconnect true, das sorgt dafür, dass wenn der Access-Point
mal abkackt, er sich versucht wieder zu verbinden, was allerdings meistens nicht funktioniert,
so und jetzt sagen wir hier SSID, das steht in der Secrets und Passport steht auch in
der Secrets-Datei, dass ich es hier nicht aus Versehen liege und damit versucht er sich
im WLAN einzuloggen, danach macht er eine Schleife, solange bis der WLAN connected ist, sollte
es länger als 5 Sekunden dauern, sich zum WLAN zu verbinden, dann startet er neu, sicher
ist sicher, vielleicht ist irgendwas schepp, an der Stelle komme ich halt nicht an den
Controller mehr dran, das heißt im Prinzip ist es besser erstmal neu starten, so hier
gibt er aus, ich verbinde, ich verbinde, ich verbinde, da läuft dann quasi so ein kleiner
Fortschrittsanzeige, so und dann kommt noch was cooles, das habe ich auf YouTube gefunden
in einem Video schon vor einer Weile und zwar ich setze einen NTP-Server, dass die Uhrzeit
stimmt und das funktioniert folgendermaßen, das ist eigentlich ganz praktisch, weil normalerweise
stimmt bei diesen ganzen Microcontrollern die Uhrzeit nie, die Uhrzeit ist standardmäßig
entweder Unix-Time, also 1970 oder aber irgendein Datum vom Hersteller, damit die Dinger die
richtige Uhrzeit locken, wie man hier sieht, also 5.6., ne 6.5., Amidatum, OMFG, 6.5., 20.03., da muss man erstmal einen NTP-Server setzen, das geht folgendermaßen, das ist super kryptisch, deswegen habe ich mir das, das habe ich aus einem YouTube-Video,
das hier, also das hier ist der NTP-Server und das hier ist die Zeitzonen-Infos, die man
braucht, richtig, richtig hängen geblieben, also wer das checkt, der hat echt Big Brain,
ich versuche es mal ungefähr zu erklären, was diese Zeitzonen-Informationen sagen, sofern
ich aus dem Kopf zusammenkriege, das hier ist, was es für Zeitzonen gibt, es gibt CET-1
und CEST-2, das ist hier die, das hier sind irgendwie die Informationen, wann, um wie viel
Uhr umgeschaltet wird zwischen Sommer- und Winterzeit, aber frag mich jetzt nicht, was
das genau bedeutet und zumindest daraus, aus diesen Zeit-Informationen und dem NTP-Server
kann er sich dann aufgrund auch der Laufzeiten zwischen dem Server errechnen, wie viel Uhr
es ist und das alles nur, dass die Uhrzeit in den Logs stimmt, so, dann hat er, genau,
jetzt hat er WLAN initialisiert, hat einen NTP-Server gesetzt, das ist eigentlich alles,
was ich noch hinzugefügt habe seit dem letzten Stream, dass er einen NTP-Server hinzusetzt,
hinzufügt den Rest, haben wir alles im Stream zusammen gemacht, so, was er als nächstes
macht ist, nachdem er das Start abgemacht hat, genau, macht erst mal WLAN an, dann startet
er den Admin-Server, den Admin-Server, das ist das Ding, wo ich über WLAN später eine
neue Firmware hochladen kann, das zeige ich euch gleich und dann startet er noch ein paar
Hintergrund-Tasks, Threads, wie auch immer man das jetzt hier genau nennen will, und
das macht er hier, und das ist aus folgendem Grund, und zwar, der guckt nach alle, also
guckt eigentlich die ganze Zeit auf dem zweiten Prozessor nach, ob WLAN noch verbunden ist,
wenn WLAN nicht verbunden ist, verbindet er sich wieder, und er gibt alle 10 Sekunden
eine Ich-lebe-noch-Nachricht aus, mehr macht der Hintergrund-Thread nicht, aber der ESP32
hat zwei CPUs, das heißt, wir können irgendeine Probleme hier unserer Hauptlogik laufen lassen,
und nebenbei noch so ein paar Service-Sachen ausprobieren, der guckt zum Beispiel auch,
ob jemand eine neue Firmware hochladen will, und dann geht es weiter.